mais si l'on bonsoir
claude allègre grands chercheurs
ex-ministre de l'éducation nationale
sarah marshall laurent baffie alors
patron jusqu'à faire regardons déjà
c'est pas bon signe non ça va là oui ça
c'est quand elle va bien
vous souriez c'est déjà mieux
ça va vous allez bien je vois que vous
avez bien
angot christie's d'écrivains se faire
comme au tribunal angot christian
d'égalité née le 7 février 59 à
châteauroux dans l'art de pierre angot
et rachel schwartz mère d'un enfant les
honore elorza vie une philosophie
et la philosophie de christine angot
bien alors vous aimez ça à la télé non
c'est un avantage
c'est que
on voit on voit on voit les gens ouais
ben dans la presse dans la presse écrite
on les voit pas il ya des gens qui les
recouvre il ya des gens qui recouvre
d'autres gens dans la presse écrite
alors qu'au moins la télé
on voit ce qui se passe quoi puis on
entend vraiment les gens parlent il
avoue rencontrer claude allègre n'aurait
peut-être jamais rencontré ah non non
c'est pas ça s'est passé d'accord c'est
sympa pour lui
pas pour moi que je trouve ça bien la tv
je trouve ça bien pour les gens qui
regardent oui j'espère alors page 27
vous dites d'ailleurs de votre livre
dont on va parler ce soir vous dites je
ne devrait pas passer à la télé mais moi
j'aime ça passait à la télé ça donne
l'occasion de parler de dire des trucs
j'aime bien dire des trucs à la télé
d'ailleurs vous dites page 37 38 avoir
vu christine boutin dans cette émission
tout le monde en parle qui disait
qu'elle faisait l'amour de la cuisine
elle était vulgaire c'est christine
boutin qui vient ici pour dire qu'elle a
fait l'amour dans la cuisine en plus
ça fait moins de scandale que vous quand
vous avez dix chez ben harper vous vous
aimiez pas l'auteur de gallimard
laclavetine
je trouve ça oui c'est finalement comme
si c'était habituel la vulgarité qu'on
s'habitue est à la vulgarité alors qu'on
s'habitue pas la vérité la vérité c'est
une chose qui est plus dérangeante que
la vulgarité oui enfin ça ça passe pas
trop alors que la vulgarité on peut
aller très très loin ça passe toujours
ce qui vous surprend le plus à vous je
dis ça je vais lui dans votre livre
c'est que boutin en fait elle dit
qu'elle fait l'amour avec son mari dans
la cuisine mon sens encore après tout le
fait ce qu'elle veut mais elle est quand
même avec lui depuis 31 ans et elle dit
ça fait pas longtemps j'ai fait l'amour
dans la cuisine donc ça veut dire que
chez les boutin ça va vous parler de
votre passage dans dans votre livre
quitter la ville combat on va parler
vous parlez de votre passage à tout le
monde en parle
dans cette émission c'est à dire que je
parle de tout ça sorte vous parlez de la
part de tout ce qui va pas quoi on doit
être un donc et de tout ce qui va pas
mais comment quand même dans tout ce qui
n'a pas comme dans la vie en général on
peut quand même passé et que voilà c'est
pour ça que je parle de de tout le monde
en parle parce que normalement moi je
sais ce que j'ai à faire à tout le monde
en parle rien et moi ben oui pas grand
chose mais bon et vous qui regardez vous
pourrez vous changez pas de chaîne
finalement c'est ça alors on va voir de
quoi vous parlez dans votre livre ça
peut leur
page 206 là quand même ces violents
incendies
son père l'a forcé à manger des
clémentines sur son sexe ses l'inceste
il l'a sodomisée seulement après il
allait à la pharmacie acheter de la
vaseline et je voudrais savoir parce
qu'il fait rire david avec clémentine
célarié
c'est parce qu'elle s'appelle clementi
gens ont ri parce que je pensais avoir
fait ventiler pas d'accord oui mais
voyez mais son père d'avancé à manger
des clémentines sur son sexe non mais
faut soit vous êtes marais non je me
suis mariée ce que j'ai entendu des gens
rigolaient
on en parlait déjà plus
voilà donc c'est vrai que ça rigole des
fois souvent de choses on ne comprend
pas
c'est vrai non mais c'est un sujet quand
même des pieds que vous êtes arrivé sur
le plateau vous n'avez pas sourit même
ri une seule fois ci qu'est ce qui vous
fait rêver qu'est ce qui vous fait rire
la question de neuneu n'est pas un
rythme c'est invraisemblable ce genre de
questions
vous fait rire et rêver enfin voyez ces
gens ne seront que voilà donc ça c'est
la dernière fois qu'il est venu dans
l'émission et vous avez été méchante
avec linda hardy du cou à des parties
alors vous dites alors dans votre
bouquin en parlant de sa clémentine
célarié menti fier d'avoir à se
justifier à tellerie angola vue pas le
téléspectateur le public a ri david
hallyday arrive ils ont ri après que
thierry ardisson a lu pages de santis et
c'est ce qu'on vient de voir et vous
continuez tous on rit maintenant ils
sont gênés maintenant génique ils sont
les invités fixe le petit écran qu'ils
ont chacun dans l'invention qui leur
permet de tamiser le réel par sa
représentation clémentine j'ai ri parce
que les gens ont ri parce que je pensais
qu'il pensait à moi david hallyday on
rigole souvent des choses qu'on ne
comprend pas personne ne relève et
d'émission continue linda hardy la
coanimatrice qu'est ce qui vous fait
rêver et christine angot dont vous aviez
jeter un vrai froid
voulait dire avec ce passage oui parce
que vous leur avez demandé pourquoi ils
ont ri c'est vrai que la réaction
humaine devant 2 devant une phrase comme
ça c'est une réaction humaine
c'est une réaction naturelle
contradictions sociales ses pour
l'action se fait à c'est vraiment un
truc quand on dit une phrase qu'elle a
que la crudité de celles que j'ai cité
de votre précédent livre donc s'appeler
l'inceste les gens rient ce une façon de
se défendre devant une telle violence
exactement je prends bien les gens ont
tort de se défendre parce qu'à force de
se défendre il ne protège pas les autres
et c'est toujours les
les mêmes qui sont dans les places qui
sont à la place d'être attaqué et ça
suffit quoi j'en ai marre de ça vient
alors le livre dont on parle depuis cinq
minutes c'est celui là donc c'est
christine angot
et c'est chez stock alors vous raconter
la sortie de l'inceste votre livre
précédent donc qui a fait certains
scandales on peut le dire non d'une
certaine façon disons que c'est
tellement disproportionné c'est
tellement
papa papale pas dans les chiffres de
pour moi la première de voir un livre
dont je pensais le titre complètement
rédhibitoire comme ça de faire quand je
veux le voir comme ça se vendre de
devoir de la maison de la presse il y
avait un truc complètement décalé si
vous voulez c'est l'histoire quitter la
ville des gens qui sont pas leur place
c'est à dire nous tous c'est à dire
c'est le fait qu'un livre ne soit pas sa
place une personne n'est pas à sa place
vous n'êtes pas à votre place personne
personne et à sa place et effectivement
tout le monde change tout le temps c'est
comme on n'est pas à notre place on
n'arrête pas de se piquer les placer un
des souris ben oui on abroge pas parce
que c'est un permis d'un homme est
génial c'est que moi j'ai lu son livre
et elle fait un bouquin sur la sortie de
ce fait il n'en restait de 26 à facebook
font en lisant ce livre si je sais tu
fais pas je entendu parler christine tu
m'écoutes sinon je te claque ne sais pas
et je sais qu'elle va faire par la suite
un litre sur la sortie de ce livre là et
que je serai de d'annoncer un sur deux
vous parlez de bouillon de culture de
passage à bouillon de culture donc le
masque et la plume sur france inter vous
étiez traitée de [ __ ] quand même c'est
rarement le masque et la plume non c'est
rare que des écrivains soit soit traitée
de [ __ ] alors qu'en fait il devrait
l'être tout le temps et c'est vraiment
ce que les gens la prostitution
non c'est pas ce n'est pas la
prostitution mais en revanche c'est ce
que les gens pensent essai c'est
mépriser les écrivains c'est comme les
acteurs c'est sylvain c'est quelqu'un
qui se met à nu devant tout le monde
doit y ait de l'argent c'était un cd à
la prostitution non parce que c'est ce
sens j'étais d'accord claude je sais pas
c'est évidemment pas vous savez
je pense bien que c'est pas c'est pas ça
s'est passé pas se mettre à nu c'est
mettre à nu les autres et c'est pas pour
gagner de l'argent parce que sinon je
pense vraiment qu'elle met à 1
vous parlez des articles qui sont sortis
à l'époque des ragots et en gros c'est
un peu la tragédie de passe comme ça
qu'on peut le voir la tragédie un peu de
candide au pays du showbiz que ça d'un
seul coup vous êtes mêlée comme ça c'est
un gros succès c'est la tragédie face à
la tragédie en tout cas celle aventures
de de faire un chemin c'est quand on
fait un chemin et ben il ya des trucs
qui se passent voilà c'est ça alors je
vous ai quand même donné une certaine
stature médiatique vous déclarez dangers
du sun en paris match désormais tous
paris match et ce qu'ils ont fait mais
c'est à lui de le dire moi je dis donc
ouais moi je nie dans paris match je me
dis quand même en gohelle elle se la
pète un peu comme on dit en parlant de
michael mais vous
vous dites dans match désormais tout ce
que je dit ou écrit atteint des
proportions énormes
voulait peut-être pas dit mais c'est ce
qui est écrit dans le journal
maintenant on m'écoute
ce que je dis c'est que pendant dix ans
j'ai publié des livres
et que et qu'il y avait aucune résonance
médiatique qui voit là il y avait
absolument aucun écho bon ce qui se
passe effectivement l'année dernière
c'est c'est juste un changement pape or
un volume sonore c'est tout alors votre
livre alors on découvre en lisant ce
bouquin très intéressant le petit monde
le milieu littéraire on voit par exemple
commencer le bouquin sur cette phrase
vous êtes obsédé par les ventes vont
commencer le bouquet en disant je suis
cinquième fils de l'ex mais je ne suis
pas obsédé par les ventes je suis
j'ai besoin de dire ce que c'est que de
faire un trajet un moment il ya tout un
truc aussi sur ce que sait par exemple
que le trajet du lis je dis que ce
trajet décrire par exemple les bains
c'est aussi de prendre la mer sur un
bateau et
c'est le trajet de très belles avec
ulysse cela dit quand on est le bouquin
on est tenu au courant page par page des
ventes à l'unité près et là c'est ce que
tu en prends un bateau on a besoin de
regarder à quelle vitesse le vent va
tourner c'est pareil vous êtes combien
que l'autre sur l'a10 l'express
je sais pas essayer document de sept
premiers ben c'est bien je vais mettre
dans votre prochain livre je suis
premier le régime de l'ex mais c'est pas
une aventure littéraire non france alors
j'ai la gueule toi
vous calculez l'argent que vous gagnez
vous dites par exemple ça me rapporter
700 mille francs alors qu'il est
mensualisé ses 700 mille francs va me
les donner voilà il faudrait rembourser
davantage moi ce sera sept cent mille
francs on va nous donner c'est marrant
je vais vous raconter vraiment le
quotidien je dis pas que c'est
inintéressant j'ai dit que c'est inédit
en tous cas je ne me dit voilà je ne dis
pas parce que je pense que c'est
intéressant je le dis parce que
des trucs qui sont dans la vie et elle
c'est la vie qui débouche dans
l'écriture c'est la vue qui est nourrie
l'écriture c'est la vie qui va vers
l'écriture il ya ce type que vous
dézinguer chez pivot qui est un mec de
chez gallimard et qui s'appelle
laclavetine après avoir tué la clape
c'est laclavetine appelons le comme ça
sollers modiano et p&o elle ne l'appelle
plus toute façon que comme ça après
l'émission il est parti quinze jours à
l'étranger son éditrice n'a pas pu aller
dîner avec lui après l'émission le père
dont elle ne voulait pas manger avec le
patron de gallimard et est en rage il a
dit après ça qui peut avoir envie
d'envoyer des manuscrits c'est le pire
représentant de chez gallimard mois
après là c'est vous vous passez devant
une librairie s'appelle la une il y
avait sa photo il m'attirait j'ai mais
son regard me devais de le dézinguer à
mort je me disais on aurait pu être à
man au lieu de s'entretuer en public si
je m'étais écouter j'aurais téléphoné et
j'aurais proposé lui prendre un café
alors qu'évidemment c'est plus possible
du tout c'est assez joli ça vous l'avez
écrasé le mec et en sortant vous à
l'espèce de compassion voyant son
portrait dans une librairie à saint
germain s'est pas bien fou pardon c'est
pas bien finalement si c'est bien mais
non faut être capable de compassion pour
ce type vous êtes là certaine tendresse
une certaine pitié paul sais c'est
difficile vous dire moi je suis j'ai
l'impression qu'il faut venir la
télévision et puis on n'y arrive pas là
quand vous citez sas et c'est une
horreur pourquoi mais parce que c'est
moi c'est pas mon livre pas de votre
éditeur aussi jean marc roberts qu'on a
traité de souteneur parce que comment
vous traiter de [ __ ] on a traité de
souteneur et qui la lui en tous les cas
on lui a reproché de faire une opération
marketing avec vous oui ça vous a
beaucoup fait souffrir ça on vous a dit
télérama disent qu'ils préfèrent un
auteur qui tout ce qu'il faut ça me fait
souffrir tout ce qui est faux ça me fait
souffrir ce qu'on est en train de faire
là c'est faut donc ça me fait souffrir
que celui qu'on fasse que je lis des
extraits non je ne sais pas on s'arrête
de parler de votre livre bapt être si
vous voulez ouais moi je veux bien moi
j'ai prévu un certain nombre d'extraits
parce que je pense ça peut l'intéresser
téléspectateurs maintenant si ça vous
intéresse pas en plus s'arrêter
l'autre question pense rien 6ème
aujourd'hui le clos des problèmes aux
noms soient pas [ __ ] non plus je n'ai
rien
et si on crée une bonne ambiance sur
place et difficile et hyper difficile de
parler des livres moi je crois que la
meilleure façon de parler des villes six
ans lire des passages parce que c'est
ridicule déchets taille d'un livre je
préfère en rire des passages non ça vous
gêne que je vis des passages de vote qui
va la télévision j'arrête ce que je peux
dire c'est qu'en plus des quatre
touristes bouquin ça donne pas envie
d'être référencé donne envie d'aller
travailler en usine
et ben voilà alors là je suis d'accord
mais évidemment ce que si c'est ça c'est
pas mais bien sûr c'est pas un rêve
d'être écrivain n'ont pas compris votre
bouquin voilà on en reste là pour me
saouler d'accord
mais c'était ce que disait baffie tout à
l'heure dans vous allez écrire en 98 un
livre s'appelle sujet angot et vous
revenez vous reveniez sur la réception
médiatique du précédent
là vous revenez sur la réception
médiatique du précédent ainsi quoi que
vous allez faire une fois sur deux comme
ça
un livre qui parle de la section chasse
faune on s'est calé jeudi que la vie en
train de la vie c'est tout
ça est le suivant vous raconter la
sortie du précédent
je ferai comme vous voulez c'est sûr
c'est un paradoxe il y en a un autre si
c'est que vous avez vendu 50 mille
exemplaires de votre du livre inceste
j'ai vu des interviews vous sembliez
être étonné en disant c'est pas normal
que ça se vende
moi moi j'étais étonné en voyant un
auteur dé en train d'expliquer que c'est
pas normal que son bouquin se vendent et
vous faites à notre bouquin et vous dis
tu là c'est pas normal qu'ils ne se
vendent pas n'hésitons pas à celui là
alors je l'aï seront pas là non ils sont
pas elles selon vous voulez que c'est
lui la suivante non il se vendra pas que
vous êtes étonné moi je vois rien je
vous l'avais dit je vous ai vue oui non
mais ça serait bien pour le livre mais
pas pour vous voilà on peut pas dire que
je sois là vous n'êtes pas vous n'êtes
pas cinquième réseau express avec ça non
là il se passe rien vous êtes déçu oui
pensions encore être
nounou non mais bien sûr je suis déçu
je pensais pas des critiques qui sont
pas très sympas elles sont même très dur
il ya benoît duteurtre ans je reste dans
paris match c'est le cas de tir mais je
vais la lire alors si
je dis juste la dernière phrase il dit
que c'est un produit sans contenu rango
n'existe que par ses postures elle se
sent obligé de revenir aussi vite donc
un an après de peur qu'on s'aperçoive
qu'elle n'existe pas il vous ni
eelv uni
tout fait quoi quand vous lisez ça le
matin en criant je vous dise oui bah moi
je me suis dit que
c'était une trahison plus dans la mesure
où j'ai fait cette interview avec paris
match avec patrick besson tous deux
patrick besson et voix c'est surtout
pauvre paris match m'a demandé de faire
cette interview très bien vous vous
allez comme ça naïvement vous dit tiens
je vais répondre aux questions que ce
type me pose il est pas mal hein mais ça
fait rien j'ai quand même essayé de
répondre et ça se passe bien parce
qu'avec patrick besson ça se passe bien
ce rapt est ce que ça se passe c'est bon
c'est intéressant c'est vraiment très
très prudents car on
n'est pas contre la main au cul l
embauche
[Musique]
à leur jeu les chauffer avec cette
histoire de femme qui adore ça qui est
pas fidèle et tout ça l'a perturbé
voulait dégraisser le mammouth rien à la
reine a dégraissé avec en gros oui et
puis à partir de là
il a essayé de me draguer mais j'en veux
pas jouer face à voir ce qui aura marqué
dans le prochain bouquin voilà et est
ensuite revenu à la pétoche
sera peut-être pas de prochain bouquin
stop
ou encore
la stop
pourquoi christine enfin je crois
vraiment ça m'amuse pas quoi mais
pourquoi on s'amusait bien nouma - non
balle est partie un
nom de ma faute c'est claude
moi je ne suis pour rien là dedans c'est
difficile de parler d'un roman vous
c'est plus facile parce que c'est un
essai non
je pense qu'un livre c'est toujours eu
l'expression d'un besoin et par
conséquent on mais est ce qu'on a dans
livres ouais c'est comme d'ailleurs
quand vous êtes chercheur cdc des médias
qui sont très difficiles chercheurs bon
alors c'est plus grande île
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de in a
l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux